in the marvel cinematic universe the
people are protected by two separate yet
equally important groups the heroes who
save them and the attorneys who clean up
their collateral damage but only one can
be both
this is her story
dun dun
she holds illegal comedy like we've
never done before
all rise
he's back now amen all right calm down
what's fun is the types of marvel
characters that come to her for legal
advice no judge is going to take this
seriously unless we do things by the
book oh the book of his chanting no the
book of american uh loss
it's a law show like ali mcbeal or the
practice
and then it breaks all those rules
the fun of the show is to combine this
legal world and all of the possibilities
around superhero weirdness
call my lawyer
i just want to be a normal anonymous
lawyer
we're really pushing boundaries
other shows haven't before
case closed
who the hell are you jennifer walters
attorney at law
jen this is your life now
whether you like it or not trouble's
gonna find you
let's do this
you could be an avenger i'm not a
superhero that is for billionaires and
narcissists
and adult orphans for some reason
she-hulk attorney at law original series
streaming august 18th only on disney
plus
you